[Music]
hello welcome to honest trailer
commentaries the show you tried to kill
but just couldn't just kept coming back
at you today we're talking about the
rock not the Johnson the movie The Rock
featuring a lot of Johnson's we're gonna
talk about that trailer we are going to
delete scenes we have to leave scenes
after that and then we're gonna tease
next week sounds trailer and respond to
comments from viewers like you
I'm joined usually as always by Joe star
yes Daniel Radford hey hey hey okay good
you're all and just to remind everyone
this show is all in support everything
we do of Direct Relief and black lives
matter links in the description of how
you can support booyakashaaa on with the
rock talk talking rock guys I find this
a fairly shallow movie to dive into and
yet I loved it and I think it's perfect
so what are all of your broad rock
thoughts perfect you think it's perfect
for what it is I enjoy it I would not
say / I think we were able to pick apart
some flaws it's not without its flaws I
just meet it like it aims to please it
aims to please like the reptilian brain
inside of you like your brainstem and
and it tickles that for probably too
long like I think your pleasure centers
are completely shot by the end of act 2
it's like that thing where they put a
rat and they were like you can either
press the pleasure button or you could
press the food button like that yes okay
thank God we lost Joe I think he had a
different opinion
I am nothing but a sucker for that 90s
Nicolas Cage like you give me any of
that stuff
you give me your face offs you give me
your Connors you give me the rock that
those are all of those are some of my
favorite movies and action movies just
because they don't take themselves
seriously they're very very very silly
and they know it
actly what it is that I want when I
watch an action movie because honestly
like all the explosions and all that
stuff all that stuff to me after a while
it just becomes white noise
I want Nick Cage uh making weird faces
and saying dumb things and it gave me
the thing that I like you gotta break it
up with that that's true and yeah that
three movie run ooh I don't think
there's a better three movie run in
certainly in action history maybe
Schwarzenegger did it somewhere but I
don't know it's gotta be gotta be the
best McTiernan had what Hunt for Red
October
those are good those are good we can
name them because there's like so few of
them well yeah I mean on other side it's
like rollerball and like it's not like
he said career right I think what one
thing that stands out to me about this
is this is from the era where action
movies stop being like there's three
action scenes you know you like one at
the beginning and then one near the end
and then grand finale to just wolde wall
like this speed and Conair where was
this new era of just we're just gonna
throw crazy stuff at you the whole time
now what makes this better to Yeldon
like a than a Transformers movie and I
think to me it because those are also
wall-to-wall action and like very
shallow characters yelling stereotypes
of each other but this one I don't know
what what makes this a [ __ ] kelsey
grammer like that money planes Kelsey
Grammer sorry Darius Crouch the third
okay a drum ball yeah I just think that
it's personality like it's you know the
only if you go back and look at those
transformers movies you know everyone in
icon air or the rock or any of these
things they make very clear character
choices that are offbeat and weird and
so you know it's it's entertaining to
like watch where Shia LaBeouf was kind
of you'd be every boy and obviously
there's that stereotype of him saying
the word know too much and the only one
who was really making kind of a strong
character choice like that
there was Bernie Mac in the first one
and then there was John Turturro who was
kind of doing some very specific
character stuff but other than that it's
just like wall-to-wall very boring
people saying very military things and
we're supposed to look to the robots for
personality and then that didn't quite
hit either whereas this is you've got
you know Sean Connery doing you know
again everyone's just making very
specific character choices and that
though the the wackiness and oddball
miss of that balances out the
wall-to-wall almost incomprehensible
action sequences yeah it is that it is
the character consistency even though
they're even though the characters are
inconsistent or in this case he's
consistently inconsistent whereas I feel
like transformers in some of his other
movies they just give jokes to anybody
or they give like the cool line to
anyone just because somebody needs to
show up and say something or because
there's a writer strike and and they're
working off an outline so it's just
fails I mean it all seems much more like
clicked in terms of being in service of
the story to like the wacky characters
are there for when they need to be there
like there's been something big or
intense has happened now we need to take
it down with Ranger Bob or whatever in
the cell to say something funny about
how he's still very upset whereas the
Transformers movies just seemed so like
scattershot and all over the place and
like just not nearly as focused as the
rock yeah that's what I was gonna say
too I feel like he was better at pace
earlier in his career like bad the first
bad boys that this even Armageddon like
there's bay hem it's like there there's
like it's just crazy chaos and the
cameras everywhere and you lose your
bearings but it's not always that he's
doing a good job of just like
establishing settings and scenes and
taking his time to give the characters a
little bit of like back and forth and
time to get to know one another and yeah
like by the transformer times it's just
like who is everybody what's even going
on like it's so chaotic and relentless
yeah like them yeah but I think you just
kind of like lost the plot at some point
well there you go so let's take a trip
back to good Bay and together we should
watch the honest trailer for a rock a
good Bay to die
this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbusters
summer blockbuster remember summer
movies we remembered summer and The
Criterion collections Michael our
pictures on by tubs the best title drop
in a movie Nick Cage division welcome to
Connor I'd like to take his face first
of all does he ever say Mandy I don't
think he does things that full Barry
Manilow song yeah what's the best what's
the best non Nic Cage title dropper is
welcome to the rock the one you can
sound off in the comments some kind of
Suicide Squad
this is your training day what are we
some kind of Suicide Squad is yeah
you're not gonna beat that let's keep
Alcatraz has been captured by terrorists
and San Francisco is in the crosshairs
now the only way to stop a dangerously
unstable chemical weapon is with a
chemically unstable
dangerous man find some Rockets lead
Stanley Goodspeed
he's a scared little dork slash badass
adrenaline junkie slash Beatles freak
whose big one-liner is an Elton John
song or the rocket movie but don't worry
this irrational character makes perfect
sense because he's being played by 90s
Nic Cage what do you see we cut the
chitchat pause the the Beatles thing was
like did that ever pay off I've never
noticed that until I think that was a
you joke Spencer I don't know he paid
600 bucks in the beginning for four
that's on vinyl great pains cause it's
not only that he's just like a collector
like it's very specifically I'm a Beatle
maniac and then not only does it not
ever pay off but then they pay off a
different classic rock act it's very
frustrating when he could have been like
you're Lucy in the sky or just he bought
a copy of like madmen across the water
on vinyl instead of goodbye yellow brick
road like their iconic Elton John albums
totally but you know what is this also
his Karen his inconsistent character
being consistent like cuz he's just out
all over the place man you never know
what to expect from Stanley Goodspeed
that's true
it's super unpredictable and yeah
there's the I think we cut it I don't
know if I made the deleted scenes but
like he's very clearly established as
like a hard sciences stem guy who like
just loves ke burns office eyebrows this
chemistry set and stuff like that and
he's going like like ancient Greek for
ancient Greek with Sean Connery the
whole movie like he's always pulling
these references of like oh it's King
Lear whatever like he's this guy's a
genius
yes it absolutely polyglot genius
there's there's that he'll see where
Connery is like you're too educated to
be an FBI agent which is like they're
uneducated like they go to school ya
know King Lear you gotta have to pass a
lot of school to be an FBI agent that's
why yeah it's kind of a yeah it's a big
deal you have to that's like the
giveaway to Conor like undereducated man
I think you won yeah or I think he
approaches character is like smart guy
dumb guy like it's binary no he's a
smart guy he knows that's the you know
smart guy stuff it's smart cop bad cop
yep
okay let's keep going what do you see we
cut the chitchat a halt although that's
only because they couldn't get Arnold
Schwarzenegger what that makes even less
sense
oh how in the name of Zeus's pothole
yeah just doesn't work to take the rock
they need a man who knows it inside and
out from its Mega Man style fling traps
to the elaborate network of tunnels
underneath which seemed stupid at the
time until he turned out to be real 20
years after the movie came out help will
come in the form of Mason John Mason a
man who demands you shut up and listen
while he's talking because he adds a Shh
to every word of her Magisters we
retired of course together they'll take
on the rogue general Frank Hummel a
retired war hero who's getting way too
nice for this I need you to tell you
teaches upon I think this is what makes
the movie great is the villain like he
is a brilliantly realized character and
played like with way more seriousness
than the movie deserves by Ed Harris
yeah ed Harris is gonna bring it a
hundred percent if it's Gio storm if
it's the rock if it's a real movie he
does not care he's he's showing up
that's another thing that I think this
movie does really well is all of the
characters even if it's like little
groups of characters not the individuals
but everyone has their little mini arcs
and like moments in the Sun and I love
that it's not just their bad you have
this weird like I love the conflict
between the villains of like this old
guard that has honor and we're still
soldiers damn it and we're fighting for
what's riding these other guys that are
like no sir we're mercenaries and
mercenaries get paid before they go back
into that mirror or whatever Candyman
says people stick our name several times
we come and kill yes I always I always
like sort of like loved that and yeah I
think without Ed Harris being the anchor
you don't get those great scenes for
like ham and John Mason meet up and you
know after Mason gets captured and they
have their like tenets set back and
forth and they're like we respect each
other yeah it's so stupid and fun yeah
if you had like John Travolta is like
castor Troy
that's the bad guy in this movie it'd be
too much it wouldn't be as good and I
don't say that lightly yeah I'm always a
sucker for the idea of like we don't
like each other and we're on opposite
sides but I respect you between the hero
and a villain that's I'm a sucker for
that trouble oh go ahead one I was gonna
say I don't know the actor who plays
like his [ __ ] huh moles contact in the
government like the other general but
that guy does a really good job of light
just very quickly like these two guys
have known each other for decades and
probably don't get along like hey Frank
well I'm here with the president you
know like it's just it's the very subtle
thing but it really helps establish the
character that like Oh everybody knows
Frank Hubble he's you know the general
he's been around and everybody's here
for years I think I made the note
somewhere and just didn't end up using
it or sending it but it was like this is
the first movie I can remember that
deserved the Revenge of the Sith crawl
line of there's heroes on both sides you
do kind of I don't know like the the
military fetish thing was Bane really
pays off by opening the movie with a
military guy who's like the military
screwed us
so you root for the guy automatically
because he's a he's like a military
boner in a Michael Bay movie so you want
it to win but it's also the bad guy and
it's a clear subversion of the Michael
Bay trope which is perhaps in The
Criterion Collection yeah I would watch
a rock prequel and then you could get in
the hole you know is Sean Connery James
Bond thing you know a young humble versa
first a young Bond I've been totally
into that when he was running guns into
Guadalajara yeah yeah all right let's
keep going there's I need you to tell
your teacher that you need to get back
on the boat and go right now
being detained against your will for
that I apologize no one has to die here
I'm not ready to kill these people I'm
not about to kill 80,000 innocent people
do you think I'm out of my mind
missions over how did this kindly old
man survive Vietnam and everyone
supported by I can't hear anything yeah
I think it cut out oh hey everyone I
thank you so much for being with us
every day subscribe to our channel what
a pro Danielle what a pro hit that like
us this Wednesday we have our hey fandom
which Janet Varney
at 10:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
because this will be before sju tomorrow
so just make sure you come a little bit
earlier go ahead and get you wake up on
because that's gonna be really fun just
to be talking to us and Legend of Korra
and and some other stuff and you can
come in again you know it'll be
streaming but you can join us and hit
that link so that you can come in and
ask questions because we want to hear
from you this isn't just about us asking
her questions it is for all of you to
come in if you don't want to be on
camera you can just do it by text you
don't have to necessarily be on camera
but also drop it so you need to get on
camera so like get some lighting and put
some makeup on yeah there you go yeah
it's like going to a Q&A at Comic Con
without waiting in line for four hours
yeah it's great that's great and you
could see the person that you're asking
questions to you know way in the back
exactly yeah
let me know when that is ready to go
again otherwise we'll talk about the oh
sure we can talk about the absolute
platoon of awesome side characters in
this movie this movie works more than
like a transformers or something like
that yeah and they're all extremely
sweaty
so hot on Alcatraz this day and it's the
kind of sweat works like what do you put
the dirt on first and then spray them
down or do you spray them down and then
put on the dirt because it's a very
grainy kind of sweaty it's not that very
speaking of the rock it's not that very
rest they're kind of sweaty where it's
like oh you just rub them in baby oil
this is
like baby oil mixed with car grease
everyone looks disgusting and like they
haven't showered makini days I mean they
did crawling like through the sewer
system to get into Alcatraz yeah this
track means generally sweaty people
hurting themselves even that much like
once they're in they're just kind of
waiting around it's very telling snow
it's tents look like they just finished
like a CrossFit workout like it's beads
all over the feeling that this is one of
those movies were between takes Michael
Bay was like let's do some push-ups yeah
I feel like though that gang of
character actors does that anyways like
they're all shaving with knives and like
yeah I mean it's like I guess just to be
that clenched so you can like issue your
dialogue with that like level of
intensity that you know they're all like
thank you sure like nobody's just saying
lime I guess you got to keep yourself
off and stuff for that frame they've got
like one of the other guys is just
squeezing a guy's nipple so he can get
those lines delivered yeah Bros knew on
acid Isis that's how you're a supporting
actor in Candyman just gonna just
shaking it yeah yeah I learned that in
school so the purple nurple School of
Acting gotta love it
good and everyone supported by a boat's
worth of badass character actors who get
to look cool and say a couple of lines
what do you have a big water pistol you
know goddamn well
now these guys these are my Avengers
right here
get ready Adam Michael Bay to turn the
bay area into the Bay Area with his
signature explosions us trolley was then
loaded with explosives of wheelchair
athletes huh never noticed that one
before because his man trained at a
chemical nerd and it always by saving
the day doesn't even start until after a
whole other action movie about them
teaming up in a film with so many well
directed action scenes you'll dare to
ask is this what a good Michael Bay
movie looks like and did that without
pause just to talk about the what lon
was saying earlier about how this is the
first film to liberally sprinkle action
scenes throughout the whole thing
sadly looking into it that's a result of
audience testing where he was showing an
early cut of this film to a test
audience and they got bored in act 1 and
he decided to insert a chase scene just
because they were getting bored so so
let's do Hummer vs. Lamborghini but if
he didn't escape what's the point of
that whole sequence they just just like
wanted to go get a shower yeah I think
it was just a more straightforward like
he snuck out and saw his daughter like
there wasn't the Oh like there wasn't a
chase right so yeah you know don't
always listen to what are they called
not like yeah yeah but it's also like
you could there's a version of this
movie where you only spend 15 20 minutes
on everything until they get to Alcatraz
like you could do this very efficiently
you could know you could I'm not saying
it's better I'm just saying like that
was a there were all set of choices that
created this movie that we had nicely
the Family Circus approach to a first
act yeah not like you could literally
open with the package like his cage
opening the thing and
little glass they you know whatever the
bomb and he's got to defuse it that he
walks out there and they ended the
assignment you're off to San Francisco
yeah man you know he got away
cut the raid where they get the gas you
need to see that that's the opening
credits is them tackling the big gas or
everything like wall Cage is traveling
to San Francisco you could cut some
Womack free Connery like there's an
effective efficient way to do it
they just didn't they were just like
what if we should go to every step of
the process then you wouldn't get that
hilarious stylist you wouldn't get the
style you wouldn't get the Womack
rivalry that that sort of pays off kinda
a little bit they tell Picasso no brush
yeah you need wall Mack because wall
Mack reinforces and Harris's claim that
the government's corrupt you ain't you
you need the proof yeah otherwise in
Harris is just like a rambling crazy
person yeah and it's like the payoff of
at the end they go fine Mason's old
files and it's like you want to root for
them and so you need to be rooting
against Womack for that yeah yeah
but maybe you can tell that it's it was
a maybe a later addition to the script
because they've spent so much time
establishing Nick Cage as a as a nerd
who's never been in the field and he
turns into like Dom Toretto drive
through buildings Ferrari man yeah sorry
brain well why not ask you gonna enter
that we say yes
come to think of it all the bass best
covers rock based oh they got my toe can
they reattach it so do a little bit
better than your best losers always
whine about their best winners go home
and the prom queen
for an on screen cluster that was only
matched by the one going on off screen
with Sorkin and Tarantino being brought
in for rewrites co-producers OD on
cocaine during production and BAE
walking off his own movie till they
agree to spend millions on a 30-second
underwater see basically this moment but
cool I take I try to take people on an
emotional ride and excuse me I'm sorry
I'm sorry okay possible so much so much
to talk about
I mean I do think that that is pretty
incredible given that he'd only done bad
boys before I guess like as far as a big
movie like he made music videos in like
victorious the air and Virgil yeah yeah
but I mean wow that's a that's a pretty
ballsy move to say oh you're not getting
this tiny like kind of throwaway
sequence for how the Navy SEALs got from
the boat inside the prison I'm quitting
the movie and like they were they were
threatening lawsuits like it got really
hairy but he stood his ground and they
put that thirty Seconds I can't imagine
that you would be able to get away with
that today like that's very much I think
when we were respecting like the
author's vision hmm
you know the auteur of Michael Bay
because now I feel like they would just
replace you right like even at that
stage in production yeah you're set if
you're two movies in yeah I think I
think I think Bank could throw even more
temper tantrums now like you're not
actually gonna let me train 10,000
guerrillas to push over the Statue of
Liberty like God but yeah I feel like it
might this the 80s and 90s there was
like this cultural thing like director
kind of supposed to be arrogant crazy
dictatorial like that was just like the
James Cameron model for it and I think
now it's become like producers have the
power and it's like everybody wants to
be like the Kevin Feige not the James
Cameron anymore so yeah it's just that
our dynamic has really shifted and now
it's like no no do your job or we'll
just fire you get something else in
reading about it I mean maybe Megan Fox
would have a different thing to say but
like actors were all gushing about
Michael Bay but saying that like he's
great to work with as an actor but he's
like a terror to everybody else so maybe
that maybe that kind of has insulated
him also many of them had to wear
bikinis that was like Nic Cage and Sean
Connery talking so it's had a weird
feeling that the poor woman that plays
Claire Fleur Anees friend probably got
the carwash audition there's just
something about just like oh that is a
yeah Oh BAE type that's just here he was
he was he was having dinner one night it
was like her she's in my movie yeah -
something chew on I guess yeah he was
also he it must have been strange him
directing Sean Connery you know like
Sean Connery is a serious actor he's a
he's a movie legend and he was being
asked to do some pretty silly stuff yeah
I guess once your post Dragonheart I
wonder if you're just like yeah sure a
lot of nineties movies where he's doing
pretty goofy shenanigans
it's a dragon machine where Claire
flourishes you're not my father and I
give her a slap stop suggesting that
shot thing that happened in the 90s were
a lot of very respected actors were
suddenly like I'm just gonna go goofy
I've had my I've had my run like I yeah
that's because although when De Niro
Pacino Nicholson they all started doing
those kinds of role
it's like remember when I used to be a
tough guy now it's silly yeah
god bless it and now we have dunkaccino
so thank you thank you for paving the
way ok they walking off his own movie
till they agree to spend movie under
water million times
basically this moment but cool I take
yeah just gonna lose in the crowd for
that did you know that pause what I was
I was physically present for this
Michael Bay chemistry thing we used I
used to work on a show and we were
sponsored by Samsung and every year we
would go coverage CES from the Samsung
lounge wow that is a stamp ton
presentation so we were like they
invited I you gotta come to our keynote
Michael Bay is gonna be there so yeah I
was standing in the bathroom as this was
happening with a bunch of Samsung people
like what's going on that's how is he
supposed to leave that's incredibly
great oh yeah I mean what fascinates me
about that clip is like Michael Bay you
know on in certain ways is is a smart
man he's gotta be able to like know how
to speak about visual fidelity and like
the movies at a pretty high level like
he couldn't just riff about like making
movies and how good that television
looks he never needs a script for his
movies why does he need a script time
television it just baffles me that he
couldn't like string together you know
or just do a back and forth with it with
the Samsung dweeb about like how great
it looks to be on a curved television
also I'm surprised that he just doesn't
have those flash papers of you that like
magicians have where it's like if he
can't think of what to say he just sets
it on side
[Laughter]
good times okay yeah all right let's do
the explosion transition to starting
excuse me I'm sorry I'm sorry okay story
we have no choice but to Stanley
double-oh-seven general grievance navy
bean we can take the nerve gas turn your
face to goo oh the city ransom for a
million bucks or to the Candy Man can
what in [ __ ] Jonathan been worse Boggs
and gentlemen welcome to the rock
Channel
dwayne johnson hey fellas if your girl
ask you to communicate more in the
bedroom this is not what they mean I
have so many questions
Nick Cage thing where he just wants to
talk about peaches yeah ok I'm gonna try
to say this in a way that's not too
gross is he trying to prolong the
experience is he trying to delay the
inevitable or is he trying to encourage
is he trying to make himself more like
the rock is it true I get it he's like
he's trying to get it up or slow it down
you're right you're saying is this like
him talk thinking about baseball is this
him like yeah Margaret Thatcher naked on
a cold day or is this yeah she's working
real hard and he's trying to meet her
efforts so he's going I just really read
this as like this is what what Nicolas
Cage thinks people do during lovemaking
like it's just it isn't just his
interpretation about Stanley Goodspeed
were three or so stage in the act
yeah a chatterbox so crypts
it's so it's the least realistic movie
sex maybe ever I think yeah we'll see
you look like you know National
Geographic pretty grounded by composure
during the showgirls pool scene they've
just been going nothing although you
know what I'll say this if if you are
that talkative during lovemaking and
after a matter that woman stays marry
her marry her yeah she's willing to put
up with that yeah yeah that's your soul
mate right there she's stuck
that's wifey material you got to lock
that down there you go good for them all
right I think we got some deleted scenes
ready if y'all would like to Peru
those let's play him you'll dare to ask
is this what a good Michael Bay movie
looks like and to that we say yes but
still you know I never saw you throw
that gentleman off the balcony all I
care about
are you happy story
- terminus the Sean shank redemption
struck at Womack the but Hurt Locker GN
Edie Edie grimly what wome a quads come
with me if you want the doll
we'd be new Ranger danger straight eye
of a queer guy Conair to con land my
chemical bromance how does one way human
life 1 million civilians against 81
hostages who is the president talking to
he's making the speech to one guy in the
room with him psycho
hey I was read that is like he's on TV
or something
but no he's just standing and it's off
it's maybe that's just how he talks he's
like a very Bartlett style do you want
me to write this down sir it's good
stuff yeah the visioning circuit showed
up for one day just wrote that speech
handed off and it's like I'm done I'm
good see I'm out yep yes dule what do
you do laying over here King tarantino
wrote oh I don't know probably like
probably like that torture stuff
he might have maybe like just just the
scenes where he's talking about music
video likes yeah The Beatles Rocketman
yeah yeah good good question all right
let's wrap man up in their third album
on the b-side man
yeah in its first trap that was about
like the bar-kays or something and like
we talked about
I Drive the Ferrari past a club for the
five six seven eight so playing yeah oh
yeah and anytime someone's foot is it's
like I don't think all of these people
would visit Alcatraz beer definitely a
cutscene where Claire flora is getting
dressed to go meet her father and she's
just putting on a shoe just with her
heel just straight up and frame that
everything else is out of focus it's
just but alright so let's go through
some viewer comments
Langly me Lee what's up rights they did
better work in the 90s because he had to
answer to people yeah is that true I
guess so
I mean there was like a certainly a
power struggle going on but he didn't
have like the blank check yes today for
sure yeah I mean I think there's
definitely something to that they're
just even just knowing that you've got
to get this past other people versus
it's my vision all the way probably
impacts some of the businesses making
you said I did that underwater scene
though so Devon bean rights everyone
plays it serious but Sean Connery I mean
to an extent I think that there's some
people hamming it up Nick Cage for one
but he kind of always takes things to
that level yeah Sean Connery that was
like he's like playing it with a wink
and a smile but he still he still got
some gravitas there he's not like
completely goofy the different military
guys are at varying states of intensity
like some of them are playing it like
playing it like you know under playing
and keeping it subtle but Tony Todd is
like real bacon who's the other the
other like really evil one who's wit
Tony Todd yeah like yeah like kind of
like redneck II what yeah he's in other
redneck things where he's arrest yeah he
always plays that like kind of angry
can't you can't unpredictable cagey
redneck but yeah they're they're big
whereas a lot of the other guys are sort
of like pokey would by its kind of
playing it a lot so and Tony Todd that's
just like who he is all the
quick divergence and I won't do this
anymore I was at a comedy festival
called the Cape Fear Comedy Festival and
we went to a bar a bunch of us after and
he was hosting karaoke in a bucket hat
and that is just what he sounds like him
who he is all of it
well it's a great story he was covered
with bees which I thought was strange
what Connery is I you know sort of
continuing that wink and a smile that
it's bond ling bond is always gonna play
things off like they don't matter or
they you know he's always gonna be kind
of aloof and charming like no matter how
high the stakes get so I think that's
sort of also continuing that sort of
yeah it works with this guy it's like
being one step ahead of everyone else so
he's one kind it's very bonding when
when he's like I'm still a good speed
look but of course you are
like that is a super James Miley I feel
like that light is definitely there to
be like this is James and then uh ed
Harris asking how I got involved and
he's like well I was formerly a guest of
this residence or what have ya watching
alright and finally Jonathan Wright
writes I'm not sure if Conair or the
rock would make a better Broadway
musical discuss you can almost make it
oh the Roxie Hart you could almost make
it like that well yeah everyone comes
out and like does their own thing you
can even do that he had it come in where
everyone comes out I mean I figured you
were gonna go cats Danielle and like
every supporting character and yeah
there gets their own intraductal cats
right so like Cyrus the virus has the
song introducing I forgot I don't know
any of the other cuts see I'm and I'm a
dog
they have cats cat put the buddy back in
the box reprieve yeah nice yeah yeah so
good
we settled that yeah I think we've
answered
it's just the one location like it just
it works so well because there are it's
already so contained they're out of
money they just ya know thing one
elaborate set yeah and then any time you
do a Cusack scene it's just downstage in
a spot and that represents right exactly
that represents land it's a matter Co
meaning it uses occur over here the
court much like the emcee in cabaret you
guys we cracked it done oh man we should
do narrates it yeah I think we gonna do
it thank you Jonathan right appreciate
it
so yeah that's our show for today come
back tomorrow and check out the hey
fandom with Janet Varney 10 a.m. PST
that'll be right before sju tomorrow I
imagine that the links are in the
description below so please check that
out it'll be a lot of fun and then come
back for this show next week where we'll
be talking about our next trailer which
next week's gonna be a jam you guys it's
gonna be an absolute Jam so I hope you
like it and I hope we see you then
thanks for watching
bye all
[Music]
you